ball back and kickboxing back in the day  when I was an amateur when I was really  young and had no I didn't have the fight  dietitian who was the guy that looks  after us here with my meals and whatnot  I did not have him on Deck I wasn't in  the UFC  oh [ __ ] man okay I um  how do I put the  I I busted enough to make way  okay rewind let's not go to that story  no I won't I'm not gonna ask the six of  that part but  how much does that weigh I mean  you really wanted to know I guess I'm  just like I would never think oh this is  the thing yeah at the time I was young  and I was on that whole no before  fighting you was a myth  and yeah I just  and then a few grams came off 100 grams  you made weight yeah wow